kids helping kids local preschoolers are
stepping up for sick youngsters by
raising money for the Make-A-Wish
Foundation great organization great
effort Candace Charles is live this
morning from The Learning Center in
Spring Valley with their efforts Candace
good morning to you
good morning to you John good morning
folks well the young students here at
the learning experience in Road Ranch
have taken this saying it's the thought
that counts to a whole nother level for
this month-long campaign for the
Make-A-Wish Foundation granting wishes
for children with life threatening
illnesses is something the preschoolers
here at the learning experience in World
Ranch do every year this year though
they doubled how much they raised
raising a whopping 10 thousand dollars
to help wishes come true for not one but
two children dealing with
life-threatening illnesses
their impact is such a big thing for
these little kids and I hope that they
you know they truly enjoy it while
they're giving back I come in here every
day ready to show them the importance of
giving back and how how fun it could be
how good it is to give back
and absolutely rewarding now
preschoolers at The Learning Experience
centers across the country have helped
raise over a million dollars during this
campaign to grant wishes for Make-A-Wish
children now coming up find out how
these students accomplished it it's
quite the tell for now live from the
learning experience in World Ranch I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now